Argos now financial reporter for The
Washington Post
Ilan Mui here to talk about rising gas
prices so where our price is now and
where they headed and what's the future
look like well right now the national
average for a gallon of regular gasoline
is about 379 so that's significantly up
from where we were last year we've seen
a sales at gas stations rise 2.6 percent
in March compared to the previous month
so we know that gas prices are higher
than they used to be the question is how
high will they go and how long will it
take for them to get there and that's
something that's actually being debated
right now I mean obviously the unrest in
the Middle East the situation in Libya
all those things are sort of coming
together to push gas prices up now the
question is will that be sustained are
we entering a new era in which rising
global demand from emerging markets like
China India are going to be pushing up
gas prices overall for quite some time
and if that happens that could mean big
changes for the domestic economy well
we're gonna talk plenty about that
wanted to ask first mentally before
economically what that four dollar
average mark really would mean for this
country yeah well we saw we saw what
happened actually back in 2008 when gas
prices hit some more recent historic
highs in 2008 the gas price high was
four dollars and 11 cents we crossed
that barrier and you saw consumers
really charts like to change their
behaviors we saw a lot of one-stop
shopping where people consolidated trips
so that they did all of their shopping
in one place we saw folks purchase
hybrid vehicles find ways to economize
on fuel we also saw many businesses have
to pass along the higher cost of
transportation to consumers so you also
saw consumers not only get hit at the
pump but also get hit when they purchase
products that had to be shipped across
the country or even across the world as
companies pass on those costs so the
bottom line is that for consumers it can
mean real dollars out of your wallet and
what's the broad impact on the US
economy overall well that is something
that the Fed has studied and what they
found is that a sustained rise in gas
prices a ten dollar increase in the
price of a barrel of oil over time
will reduce the gross domestic product
by about 0.2% so the higher the higher
gas prices go the the lower output is in
the US and that's something again that
could potentially challenge the economic
recovery that we're trying to hold on to
right now our guest will take calls in a
moment or two Elan Mui is a financial
reporter for the Washington Post as
taught journalism courses at the
University of Maryland at College Park
started at the post in 2002 covering
education and started her career as an
obit writer at the Times Picayune
phone numbers on the bottom of the
screen for Republicans and Democrats and
independents as we begin this
conversation on gas prices and what they
mean take us deeper into the idea of the
the why evolve as you mentioned a bunch
of factors are coming together at the
same time what should folks look for if
they're reading the papers about things
happening across the world and what it's
going to mean at the pump well first of
all the thing that you want to keep your
eye on is the situation in the Middle
East
I mean clearly their major source of oil
for us and as there's turmoil there that
increases sort of speculation over what
the supply of oil is going to be like
and that can help increase prices you've
also seen situations where where
countries are sort of locking down the
their supplies were ordering them
advanced and that can also drive up
prices as a sort of fear over how much
there's going to be a left for the US so
I think that that again in the short
term is something that is driving up
prices a lot of speculation a lot of
concerns a lot of worries but in the
longer term you know are we going to be
entering an era where where where our
gasoline prices look more like Canada's
or look more like Europe where they're
very accustomed to paying you know five
six seven eight dollars a gallon you
know what is what is that scenario going
to look like as we enter into a so a
world where other countries may be the
dominate consumer force in the world so
more the statistics these from the
Energy Information Administration on
regular gas prices this is a regular
blend of gas per gallon this summer
three dollars and 86 cents is the
projected figure there last summer it
was 276 so a dollar $0.10
once their average price 370 expected
average in 2012 three dollars and 80
cents we have some video that we shot
locally of gas stations as we continue
to talk here about gas prices so we see
there 429 that was shot somewhere in the
DC area I think was actually in the
district 429 but take us elsewhere
around the country where is it highest
and lowest do you know well I think that
I think that it depends on where you are
in the country how much it can be paying
for price of gas I think that one thing
that you do find is that places that are
more highly metropolitan tend to have
higher gas prices I know that I was in
Texas recently and I couldn't believe
how cheap gas seemed but for the folks
who live there they felt like they had
seen significant increases even though
for me coming from DC to Texas it seemed
like you're getting a bargain so the gas
price of gas does vary across the nation
but I think what's important is is the
amount of increase that we're seeing
nationally and and that consumers
everywhere or feelings at the pump first
call for our gas Grand Forks North
Dakota it's Mike on the Republican line
hi Mike good morning sir
I guess in my part of the country here
we deal a lot in agriculture and we have
a lot of analysts analyzing the price of
fuel the common consensus among the
professionals is that the qe2 the Fed
injection of trillions of capital into
the world economy has brought down the
price of the dollar and because oil is
priced in dollars that means the price
of oil goes up because the currency it's
based on is going down in value that's
part of it but my concern is that
because the Fed has released trillions
of dollars into the economy that we're
getting none of the benefits in the
United States but we're getting all of
the risk our currencies going down or
price of oils being inflated but yet
none of that trillions of dollars is
being vested in the US economy sorry
we're getting crunched in every way it's
a complete disaster for the revenue
generation of our country because Ron
Paul introduced legislation which forced
the Fed to release a report about what
it's been doing in terms of lending
since the Oh eight collapse well guess
what
companies like caterpillar get one point
five trillion service and interest
Citigroup got two point five trillion
reserves and interest Goldman Sachs got
one point two trillion my point is none
of this money is being invested in the
United States because we're told that
the corporate tax rates are too high or
other conditions aren't right for
investment that the government is too
overbearing but yet if you look at where
the money is going a lot of us go into
communist government the government of
China where that government requires a
51% ownership of all foreign companies
doing business there so that means they
take half of everything upfront and
require controlling interest and our
American central bank is giving
trillions to our big multinationals at
0% interest in half of the fortune 500
companies are paying zero / zero in
taxes right so if half the fortune 500
is paying zero in taxes and our American
central bank is loaning trillions at
zero percent interest how could the
American economy move be more conducive
to investment Mike thank you
well I think that the caller brought up
a good point which is sort of what is
the Fed role in in in curbing inflation
right so higher gasoline prices can lead
to higher prices of other goods which
can lead to inflation and sort of how
will the Fed address this and I think
that what we're talking about earlier
and sort of sort of what are the root
causes of these higher prices and how
long will they last the answer to those
questions will define how the Fed
addresses the problem so if the Fed
feels like this really is something that
is a temporary spike driven by unrest
and turmoil in the Middle East that will
abate over time maybe in the next couple
of months or maybe in a year or more
that they would be shaken may be a more
hands-off approach to dealing with the
problems of rising inflation however if
they do feel like this is a sustained
problem that we are entering a sort of
new world order might they take some
monetary policy action in order to rein
in inflation in the US and which would
also impact gas prices let's hear from
Nashville Robert Democrat good morning
hi good morning I
I have to say that your previous
Republican caller was right on the money
with what he said and I did want to add
one other thing the taxes that are paid
on a gallon of gasoline is astronomical
a lot of people doesn't understand that
if you live for example in Tennessee
besides the 39 cents that the federal
government charged you or 41 cents
whatever they've driven it to now if you
took that tax out I've never heard one
politician not one Democrat Republican
independent whoever Ron Paul or anybody
in between say anything about the
elimination total elimination of taxes
on gasoline for the consumer not one
person not one politician and I suppose
that's the fear of the big oil companies
dropping the hammer on them but I'm
wondering what your guest thinks about
that and I would like to just hang up
and listen and see if she has examined
this idea and and taken it any further
then someone maybe even at the
Washington Post saying hey shut up don't
say anything about it thank you very
much appreciate your time before you
respond explain for us the tax structure
as it relates to gasoline yeah so if you
buy a gallon gas there are additional
fees that are paid within that and part
of that is sort of a tax a sort of extra
fee that's paid to the federal
government right and there have been
efforts over time to to get rid of that
tax actually they haven't gone anywhere
which is why which is why you've seen
which is why you're you see this call
are sort of worrying about you know why
are we still paying this and how how
what role can that have been reducing
the price of gas I think that the that
the the issue that a lot of a lot of
people feel when they go to the pump is
that they look at the price they're
filling up their gas tank and they're
not necessarily just even filling up
once a week they're filling it up twice
a week or sometimes even more depending
on how far you have to drive and that
sort of psychological sort of sort of a
behavioural result of having to
constantly see this higher price
constantly have to sort of feel that
pain makes often time the rise in the
price of gas feel feel even worse than
the rise and other commodities I mean
gas is risen by my significant amount
and 2.6 percent we saw in March but
that's that's you know pennies compared
to the price increases we've seen in
other commodities like cotton like sugar
but how often do you buy bag of sugar
not that often you go to the gas pump
even multiple times in a month and so
that's why consumers are really sort of
feeling this more acutely so people
still have to drive to a certain extent
so if they fill up their tank at the
higher price what happens back at home
what are they not spending money on do
you think well the the I theory is that
consumers will cut back on discretionary
purchases so that could be anything from
apparel to electronics etc but what
we've actually seen is that even though
consumers say that they will cut back
because of higher gas prices so far we
have not reached that inflection point
the Commerce Department just this week
released retail sales results for the
month of March and what they found was
that even though people were paying 2.6
percent more at gas stations they were
still spending more money at clothing
stores at electronic stores even at home
furnishing stores which is one category
that had been lagging for a while so you
still haven't actually seen consumers
reduce their spending yet even though
they say they plan to does that make
more going back to our credit cards well
there's actually credit has still fallen
off but what you're finding is that that
aggregate overall the the nation has
increased their savings and so part of
this spending may be coming from dipping
into their savings account spending a
little bit more money the other reason
the other thing you may be seeing is
that you know the nation added two
hundred sixteen thousand jobs in the
month of March so with increased jobs
that means increased wages increased
income to spend so that may be where
some of this money is coming from again
consumers say they do plan to reduce
their spending because of these higher
gasoline prices but we haven't actually
seen that born out and the numbers yet
this story in the New York Post that we
can show you points out the u.s. gas
price has ever risen for about 24
straight days
now and the headline says that the
average New York gas price may pass four
dollars this weekend our next call is
from New York City it's Danny on the
Republican line good morning hello
morning good I live in one of the
poorest counties in New York State and
it's gas prices at 399 I think we have
to blame this on the globalist
unconstitutional wars in the Middle East
I mean you know we're we're we're
fighting these countries and our gas
prices are going up you know people need
to start being more aware the new world
order and what's really happening in
this country thank you guys
new world order is the cause of all this
well that's the graph that we're talking
about before you know how long will this
be sustained and I think that one of the
the issues facing the Fed as they as
they sort of decide how to address this
inflationary problem is something that
economists call the sacrifice ratio the
sacrifice ratio is is the amount of GDP
in the Mount of domestic output that you
have to give up in order to fight
inflation by tightening the monetary
policy right so one thing that the
Chairman in fact is worried about is
that if you try too hard to rein and
inflation try too hard to rein in these
prices that actually you may end up
curtailing sort of the fragile recovery
that we're in right now and that's
obviously something that no one wants to
wrist no want to see an unemployment go
back up so these are some of the these
are some of the debates that are
actually going on right now within our
government here is a tweet this morning
the real issue here is that we have
become addicted to oil the fun part of
our addiction is over now we are hooked
makes you think about alternative fuels
alternative energy what is a situation
like where I now mean to that part of
the business well I think that you've
seen sort of the the initial sort of
buzz around hybrid vehicles die off a
little bit that doesn't mean that
they're not selling as well as they had
before clearly GW bolt that came out was
a very popular though at a very high
price range so you know you're seeing
you're seeing car sales sort of changed
you're seeing the demand for certain
types of vehicles change
using I think that there was a report
put out by by the department
transportation that found that Americans
are actually driving less than they used
to looking at more places close to home
in fact I was reading a conference call
with a Family Dollar the the retailer
that caters to some of the most
vulnerable consumers in the country and
what they found is that actually rising
gas prices were helping their traffic
because frequently their stores are
located close to the consumer close to
the communities that they serve and
folks weren't willing to drive far out
in order to purchase the products that
they needed so they were seeing a bump
in traffic because of a higher gas
prices here is a story in our guests
publication in The Washington Post
automakers still high on hydrogen cars
says the headline manufacturers press on
despite budget cuts to the program and a
lack of administration interest makes me
want to ask you more about Congress and
the administration and this whole issue
of fuel energy gas prices what have they
been saying well I think that one thing
that you'll find is that they're they're
sort of Anna quandary right now is that
and you know you found that the
administration has been a very strong
supporter of a nuclear energy but we
found with the with the situation in
Japan that there's many there's
obviously many dangers and that's
obviously something that's that's
controversial right now you know the
administration and looks at coal and
what are we find we find that miners in
West Virginia you know are in a
dangerous situation
right you look at oil and you look at
offshore drilling and you find that
we're stuck with a enormous oil spill
and in the Gulf and actually one that
recently occurred that uh they got less
attention but so that is a dangerous
place so even when you look at through
the picture right what what resource are
you going to are you going to tap that
that is safe that is not as
controversial and and that can sustain
an entire nation's energy consumption
and I think that they're trying to
navigate that right now but what they're
finding is that all the avenues that
they look at are are uphill battles
opinion piece in The Wall Street Journal
okay
you want to read oil without apologies
can Strasse allah writes about Chevron's
CEO they pull a short piece here he says
Americans must stop taking affordable
energy for granted
that means more oil gas and coal it's in
today's edition the weekend edition of
The Wall Street Journal
our guest is Ilan Mui financial reporter
for The Washington Post we have about 20
minutes left for your calls and the rest
of this Washington journal on a Saturday
Katarina Texas is our next call it's
Barry on the independent line good
morning good morning miss Louise that
last comment you just make because about
the the CEO of Chevron that takes us
back to connect the dots with the CEO of
Exxon Mobil and a congressional hearing
back in 2005 he made a comment that the
American public's can have to realize
that they're on a world economy and
that's a solution of the dick cheney oil
policy or energy policy and you see it
today right here in this area where I
live a third of the fracturing drilling
is owned by Chinese investors so you
know Chesapeake Energy Corporation is
controlled by or a third of its
controlled by Chinese investors so I
guess that's where we're living with now
a world economy and we let's hear from
our guest yeah I think that and you know
the caller said he lived in an area
where where you know he can see the real
impact of the debate over oil and where
it should come from and who should be
investing in it last summer I was in New
Orleans covering the impact of the BP
oil spill and one thing that really
struck me was that and when I talk to
the folks in the community talked to the
folks in in Port Fourchon
in in Houma Louisiana what they told me
was that I'm even though you were they
were in a situation where you found that
their livelihood at catching seafood
crabbing oysters shrimp all of that was
endangered by the spill and by some of
the the dangers of drilling offshore
that they didn't want to stop that those
that that those rigs were also providing
jobs in their community and that was
something that was also very important
to them in fact one of the the folks
that I talked to you had put a mannequin
outside of his son of his his store and
he had the arms cut off in the legs cut
off and he said you know Uncle Sam
you're cutting off our legs by cutting
out the seafood addition you're cutting
off our arms by cutting off the the oil
industry so you know what do we have
left how are we going to survive and I
think that that's something that really
and sort of touches at the heart of part
of this debate you know which is which
is American jobs right and you know who
where are we going to find the resources
in order to power the country you know
who is going to be able to provide them
to us and at the end of the day who's
gonna be paying for it we've talked a
lot about the personal aspect of all of
this the family budget what about
businesses themselves that rely on
gasoline to just do their business
what's the impact been well you're
seeing them actually absorb a lot of
that right now
and one thing that we found back in 2008
when we saw the record high oil prices
we passed that $4 a gallon mark is that
businesses added surcharges I'm even to
just order a pizza
you know pizza delivery places we're
adding fuel surcharges a dollar here $2
there at this point in time you're
seeing a lot of folks eat that cost and
if they pass on to the consumer it's not
always strictly through price they may
actually change the product itself so
for example you may find them some
stores or some manufacturers offering
smaller products maybe the can of
tomatoes instead of being 16 ounces is
now 14.5 ounces so it's something that
that's a way for them to sort of reduce
their costs but not necessarily how to
consume or notice it when they actually
go purchase our item on the shelf so
you're going to see companies pass this
on in many different ways and they're
also going to take a hit to the body
wine here is a tweet the trucker is used
to protest against high gas taxes but
now the companies own the rigs with no
unions and independent truckers are
helpless this one viewers perspective
bob is on the line now from Hazelwood
Mazzara Democrat good morning to you Bob
good morning I'm really surprised that
they're writing out this Libyan thing
and their unrest middle east to
compensate for the rising oil prices if
anybody remembers the prices started
going up around Christmas last year when
we were awarding oil
and nobody they just stood around
scratch their head is that all we know
where it is it's a speculators these
people who aren't in the oil business
but they're allowed to buy up oil
futures then they play against each
other and they all make a big fat profit
and we suffer in the economy suffers and
it's the same old thing it's like when
we invaded Iraq they're always going to
pay for the war well that's about a
trillion bucks
we haven't heard about one barrel of oil
coming from Iraq and how it's affected
prices or the world or all supply far as
a matter of fact even who is selling to
we drill for oil in Alaska and it's
going on tankers it's gone it doesn't
make any difference if we drill drill
baby drill in the waters and lose
everything and it has got nothing to do
with supply and demand well I think that
the caller made a good point and that we
actually don't receive very much oil it
all from Libya the the fear in Libya or
sort of those as the theory goes is that
it's sort of contributing to general
turmoil in the Middle East that is that
could possibly be pushing up gas prices
but Libya itself is not a major producer
of oil for the US but his other point in
terms of the price of oil being driven
out by sort of market speculators you
know if that is the case that's actually
potentially a better scenario for the
u.s. because that isn't that sort of
market-driven that that can cut that in
which the price can go both up and
couldn't come back down that doesn't
necessarily indicate a sort of
structural change in the way in global a
global demand so you know if it's
something that is merely a speculative
increase in prices hopefully that means
that there's a there's actually what
goes up must come back down right and
that prices go back down if this is
something that is more structural in
nature we could we could be in for more
pain in the long haul remind us of where
we get most of our gas from in this
country yeah so we get most of our gas
from from the Middle East Saudi Arabia
Iraq cetera are all major producers I
believe something like something like
maybe a third of the oil actually only
is produced domestically so but that is
something that is still a significant
portion of our nation's consumption and
and and that is why there's been so much
interest in in drilling both in Alaska
and in the Gulf immense and what other
countries are out there we know Canada
produces Mexico produces Nora Norway and
others what other countries might be
providing the rest to us the size of the
Middle East I mean yes um certainly and
I think that you you covered most of
them yeah okay let's move on to Fort
Myers Florida now Edward you are on the
line for independence with Elon we go
ahead where let me jump in though where
do you get your information from you
just cited two statistics what are you
reading 1960 when I invested in a
company called just five petroleum and
if it's all their paperwork that I was
getting on shale oil and the thing is
now at that time the government said
that you'd have to go to 50 cents a
gallon yeah
make it profitable to bring out Thank
You shale oil let's get a response from
our guest well I'm not entirely clear on
what what the caller was asking but I
think that part of the question was
should we be using more of our own
natural resources I think was sort of
the gist of it and you know that is
something that is under debate right now
it's not something it's something that
as the as the administration looks at
this question again we talked about the
different national natural resources
they can use oil we looked at coal we
look at nuclear and and you wonder what
is the what is the benefit each of those
each of those main sources have
undergone and we've seen have undergone
dramatic dramatic accidents dramatic
incidents over the past year and so as
you try to craft an energy policy which
one of those are you going to put your
money behind which one of those you're
going to try to put your resources
behind because we've seen that all of
them can be potentially fatal Larry
Atlanta Republican good morning to you
well how are you doing back in 2006 I I
had my own getting set up with the gas
prices and I was commuting back and
forth to work about 30 miles and I
decided that I was going to move closer
to work
I took my gas consumption from about 60
gallons a week down to about 10 gallons
a week I now spend more money going to
the grocery store and taking my kid to
the park they're not new going back and
forth to work if everybody in America
would do something along those lines
only we could become energy independent
real quick I was wondering what your
comments and what studies might show
about where the fuel is actually going
is most of it going to getting people
back and forth to work and could we
curve a lot of it simply by moving the
two closer together more about the
personal habits there right I think that
what you what you saw for
a few decades ago was sort of the the
sprawl out of America right in which
you're increasingly seeing folks move
out into not just suburban but X urban
locations you're seeing big-box stores
being located even farther and farther
away so you saw America sort of expand
now what you're seeing is actually a
desire to contract you know biking to
work is up many folks are choosing that
option folks are choosing to live by
public transportation you're also
finding folks walking to work etc so
these are some of us as the caller
mentioning some of the behavioral
changes that folks may start to make as
you see the the price of oil and the
price of gas increase but certainly
biking walking slugging to work as many
people in the Washington area do
ride-sharing all of those things are
popular options to reduce the cost on
your own personal finances here's a
question by a Twitter do you believe
regulations are raising fossil fuel
price in order to make renewable solar
when bio competitive without subsidy
well that is that is a very loaded
question what I think is that certainly
regulation is is it has a role in in
which which of these resources we focus
our attention on you know whether or not
that is that is driving a certain type
of competition or or or whether or not
that is excluding certain types of
resources you know is really is really
up for the market to bear out blaming
the president for rising gas prices is
nothing new we've seen that over the
years but speak to us more about the
political play of this issue on the hill
can a president really help or help
drive this up-and-down of gas prices
well I think it's something that
actually is really more driven by
monetary policy which is which is
separate from what the president does
but certainly this could become a
political issue I mean you know it's
these are sort of the kitchen-table
economic issues that can become that can
become real real debates in any campaign
and I think that that the issue of
rising gas prices and the issue that
folks are feeling on their wallets just
sort of contributes to the overall
concern
that you know is the recovery going to
be on track you know are we going to see
job creation occur you know if we if we
try too hard to combat this inflation
what are we going to just have to
sacrifice because of that again that
sacrifice ratio so I think that this
sort of contribute to the overall
feeling of where are we in our economy
and what are you going to do to make it
better and one issue too though that
always comes up is the US Strategic
Petroleum Reserve some people bring that
out as an option go there to put more on
the market and prices go down any
realism there is it just an issue that
people like to bring up I think it's
something that M is a constant concern
is constantly being debated but I think
that just like with the gas tanks you
haven't really seen much more than that
in the past Kansas City Missouri bill
Democrat you're on the air good morning
morning sir
here's just another way to look at
things I guess I just I just had this
about the same conversation with my
grandkids over lamenting the price of
gasoline and of course no grandkid wants
to hear about how bad it was back in the
day but I I give him another side of it
when when I was their age in 1948 my dad
had a new 1948 Buick Roadmaster
convertible that got honest eight miles
to the gallon so I was working at a fire
station I was getting fifty five cents
an hour and just do the numbers on this
now and and price of gas was a quarter
so my our labor bought 16 miles you
follow that guess you weren't driving
too far my grandkids ones making $8 an
hour if the curve a new Buick I think I
saw it gets around 32 miles per gallon
but let's just say it's even less than
that let's say it's 25 miles a gallon
for their hours labor they get at least
50 miles way more than we got in the
time and if you factor in the cost of
the upkeep of the car
for the time these cars last way longer
than they did then so there's it isn't
fair I don't think to just look at the
price of gas and say how terrible it is
unless we make some comparisons like I'm
doing here let's hear from our guest I
think that the caller brings up a very
good point is that memories are short
I remember in in 2008 when I was writing
stories about gas going up to $4 a
gallon and above and sort of the changes
that was in creating a consumer behavior
and now gas hasn't even hit $4 yet we're
already worried about seeing that happen
again so I think that memories are short
but at the same time there are certainly
ways that consumers can try to improve
the mileage on their cars even beyond
what the what the manufacturer says the
mileage may be you know some of the
things that folks are doing or things
called and hypermiling in which they you
know you sort of drive in a way to
maximize your gasoline try to break less
Drive at a certain mileage point maybe
don't go over 60 miles per hour because
that's the most efficient way to drive
your car not topping off your gas tank
between between fills waiting for it to
go all the way down before you before
use again not running your air
conditioner or not running your Heat
which may be difficult for many people
as the summer comes up but there are
certainly ways to even within even
within the car that you have now to
maximize your fuel efficiency let's hear
from Ocean County New Jersey it's
Richard on the line for Republicans hi
morning morning okay a few points two
basic things much ado about nothing and
voters you get what you deserve
first much ado about nothing it seems to
me that we're overreacting to the price
of gasoline rather than looking at the
underlying problem the politics of
gasoline and the Republican Democrat and
coastal versus Heartland divided and and
so here's the thing if if the average
driver is just using
eight hundred two thousand gallons of
gas a year a dollar or two a gallon
rise is not going to break the bank you
have ways of getting that money back if
you're like small business or even if
you're just a member of a union and you
bargain for a little bit more or you
negotiate directly with your employer
etc etc etc because the cost of living
is generally a bargaining issue or a
motivation for bargaining so we can
offset that a little bit the other thing
is with regard to you get what you
deserve when you vote the coastal
regions and the urban regions seem to go
Democratic and then the Heartland which
is spread out which doesn't have the
luxury of subway systems and mass
transit they have to use this gasoline a
lot more to get from point A to point B
and have their lives but they tend to
lean towards the Republicans and the
people who favor the oil industry and
then you have the appointments from the
Republicans on to the Supreme Court who
decide a case that says that these big
corporations are the equivalent which is
a joke
equivalent of an individual and
therefore they have the same rights and
they can spend as much money as they
want to influence the campaigns to get
more Republicans in to pull up more
Republican appointees on Supreme Court
in the other courts and rule accordingly
to keep the masses divided and conquered
and so you know I wonder are we looking
at the right thing here is that the
actual cost per gallon of gasoline or
how how these things are done I mean do
you really think that the average
individual could approach and say the
President of the United States the way
an oil company executive could so we are
equal we don't have equal bargaining
power and it's very very important for
the masses to get together think
straight and vote together for their
best interests Richard thank you well
just the caller's first point which is
this idea that I'm you can you can
offset the
the cost of the inn cost increasing
gasoline by sort of using that as a way
to bargain for higher wages or a higher
salary etc that actually is something
that you know certainly personally I
would love to see let's see it to see a
race not the cost of living but again
when you think about in the macro sense
inflation that's exactly what causes it
right the sort of wage price spiral is
that you see the cost of gasoline go up
folks
you know demand higher wages to
accommodate that so therefore so
therefore businesses feel like they can
charge more and you just see it go on
and on and on and that is exactly the
kind of thing that the Fed is looking at
and determining whether or not we will
actually need to curtail this whether or
not businesses will will accommodate
this request and and how long will it be
going on one last call Raleigh North
Carolina Alix Democrat good morning sure
a great guest very attractive very
well-spoken presents well however I'm
concerned a little bit superficial like
to hit three quick points in a limited
time the Mercantile Exchange I
understand that a lot of the oil and gas
is not included in it and that as little
is allowing the massive fluctuation in
prices by the speculators second when we
do domestic drilling much of that oil is
shipped overseas that's what the earlier
caller was saying about Alaska they're
not using it here how's it benefiting us
and then third the gas prices have
jumped up about a dollar a gallon that's
not 2% from $3 to $4 it's 30% and that
fluctuates through everything huge
impact now consumers versus citizens
before Ronald Reagan we were citizens
came to the Zoomers so I don't know I
have a problem
our existence here in the United States
final thoughts from our guest this
morning well the first thing that I'll
say is that when I talk about consumers
versus citizens is that we're talking
about gas prices and sort of their
effect on the economy and so in the
economy consumers at the driving force
of birth semester products so that's
something to look at the second thing is
that in terms of who is benefiting from
from gas production in the US I think
that you know certainly some of this may
be shipped overseas but again that would
increase our net exports and so that is
money that we would also see at home and
there would be benefit there as well and
the final thing is that when we look at
the rising gas prices you know you have
to look at it over what time frame are
we going to be comparing it to you know
certainly we can compare it to 2000 2008
and say the gas prices are actually
lower than they used to be but the the
numbers that we're looking at are
month-to-month and what we're seeing is
that the 2.6 percent rise was actually
at gasoline stations so which that
includes both fuel sales and another
sales as well our guest has been Ilan
Mui financial reporter for The
Washington Post thanks a lot for your
time and the update this morning on gas
prices thank you